Jimmy Wales one of the founders of
Wikipedia is browsing in a beautiful old
bookstore in London books have been a
lifelong source of inspiration for him
so this seemed like a great place to
meet well I was a very early reader
learn to read quite early and my house
was full of books we had encyclopedias
at home and I really loved my world book
encyclopedias yeah early in my career I
was a future as an options trader in
Chicago I thought that was really fun
and interesting it was very consultative
a lot of mathematics and so forth really
enjoyed that but I also got really
interested in the internet really
excited by the Internet when when I saw
well I as a hobby I was working on
writing a web browser whales continue
developing Wikipedia while you were
still working in finance in Chicago
that's where he made his first million
today whales is a man of independent
means and lives with his family in
London Wikipedia is now the world's
fifth most popular web site does he
regret founding it as a nonprofit no no
not at all I'm really proud of Wikipedia
as it is and you know I think you know
it's a it's a remarkable community
project that's been built by millions of
people and I think it's amazing just as
it is this shop may be full of exciting
books but what you won't find are
up-to-date multi-volume encyclopedias
the venerable Britannica for example
founded in the 1760s stopped printing
new editions in 2010 this marks a huge
change and the end of an era
how does Wales feel about this you know
Britannica was already in deep trouble
due to Microsoft Encarta and they didn't
adapt well to the digital age but then
the move to collaborative pure
production and getting many more people
involved they clearly never really
I should do anything about that so you
know in some ways of course it's sad to
see old institutions go but maybe
there's a new institution so Wikipedia
is putting ever more multimedia content
on the web music images and maps for
example Wales thinks that Peaks use as
curiosity which in turn leads them to
buy books to learn more I don't think
that Wikipedia replaces books are
textbooks or in-depth things it's a
supplement to it and it's a supplement
in the same way that I wouldn't think
that Britannica or Brockhaus could
replace Shakespeare it's one thing to go
and read about Shakespeare and
understand sort of a broad background
information and so forth but you really
need to grapple with the text according
to Wales books and Wikipedia pursue the
same goal to enlighten and inform what
do you think would be a lifetime I can
be oh it could be a lifetime achievement
I mean for me it's really Wikipedia no
this is my life's work and I have a goal
for Wikipedia to see Wikipedia have at
least 100,000 entries in every language
that has at least 1 million speakers so
this is like three hundred and forty
something languages where in about two
hundred and eighty right now
and even the Trinity don't all have a
hundred thousand entries yet so there's
still a lot of work left to do Wikipedia
is designed to continually renew itself
and grow Jimmy Wales mission is to
support that process